this plane citation needed join me today
he reads books you know it's Chris Joel
hello
everybody's favorite go runnin runnin
I'm in the old fashioned bus so my
grandmother the war he is you know and
the bouncy smell on the internet in that
gray we'll come on you two in front of
me I've got multiple from Wikipedia and
these folks can't see it every fact to
get right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for particular dancers
which is and today we are talking about
the Sark
football team okay island off Jersey
yeah have a point yeah but American
football all the boats in Greenwich what
katisa ah know already shall I leave yes
yes sock is part of the Bailiwick of
Guernsey okay fair enough are the
Channel Islands
let's let's start really real or are
they some islands in the English Channel
yeah you know at the point when I gave
you the title I don't understand the
question there are so there's something
special oh you have to be what the cold
oh Jesus there's one called Jersey
there's one called go honey and this one
called st. helens no no this is near
Wigan your thing you've st. Helena and
that's on the other side of the planet
it's okay yes Albany poisoning it is
that's one of them look I have a capital
of personnel nerve
yes I'm getting something right yeah
that's my job
what I'm saying is you're wrong it's
Saint Helier
when you say what other Tuttle islands
my standard answer is usually occupied
France yes point yes absolutely they
they were the only give a point well
that's one of the questions I was going
to ask only bit of the United Kingdom
that was actually taken by they were in
verse 19 forty nine forty or forty would
I forget the year I wasn't there one of
1940 but in terms of of Britain
what are they crowned territory yes yeah
have the point there are a Crown
dependency but they're not part of the
United Kingdom tax haven I thought I
thought you'd gone for Goldfinger they
are the same people that live there they
suck the one may you not haven't you
know you don't have any Motor Vehicles
is it still bicycles oh yes that's right
Sartre is the one where cars are banned
ladies and gentlemen the Gary Brannen
general knowledge edition the Gary's
moment of people holiday through this
photos slides this is not the car this
looks like a car but in the back it's
very large hamster wheel this looks like
a car pull up the bonnet horse crack in
what one isn't Sark one where it is
technically still run by a Lord feudal I
think he's getting all the points today
he's on home turf here come on skew the
crown territory facts bring it on it was
considered the last feudal state in
Europe until 2008 when they reformed it
but yes that will you own the island
therefore you own the people yeah pretty
much
I'll police say they how to communist
revolution you know price the reform
it's referred to now it sounds more
ominous than it's all capitalized yeah
and if you didn't like the idea would
that be suck snark negative about it Oh
um there are a lot of old laws still in
place they didn't have divorce until
was it separation of bed and table I
don't know what that is that is the way
you could organize this form of divorce
pre divorce being allowed you're allowed
to live apart by the church courts
separate men zet thora oh yeah because
you've just basically told the entire
first paragraph a completely different
yes time in three shows by the way but
how can you now get divorced on sock you
can murder the other person not
technically and that was always an
option you know Oh leave get divorce
come back yes and now get divorced in
Guernsey and come back to sock that was
a liberal Guernsey but they probably
haven't been out on islands like that
when I'm hot when I was on holiday a few
years ago I went out it's one of the
Hebrides islands I went to cold which is
similar kind of thing very small island
they have a very slightly larger
neighbor Tyree who they see has been
stuck up because here we have the coop
and V they have the policeman and what
happens is when the policeman gets on
the boat to come over they phone up the
island and everyone hides their non
registered cars and stuff until the
policeman is left and now you've just
ratted all of that yeah policemen from
entire income but by the time he's got
somewhere somewhere on the island oh we
said not to tell anyone
Gary we we briefly mentioned the economy
what is Sark's economy driven by o6
sarcasm tourism yes and you also said
that earlier financial services kids
it has a low amount of tax let's say
that how long do you have to live there
it's got to be obvious
probably I'm guessing owning a tiny tiny
tiny tiny fraction of a bit of land
counts as living there three months in a
tax year
okay ninety one day is you're good
you're a resident you get
tax laws if you want them don't do this
I'm really crap at tax stuff probably
thinking if I can do this the answer is
almost certainly no but I'm thick as
mince I don't let you near this just a
sec this means all your tax savings
could be spent on getting a hovercraft
and then you could get a hovercraft
there and that would be fun cuz it's a
hovercraft
Tom Tom please can have a go on a
hovercraft what we're saying is we all
want to go on a hover and I think I can
arrange that but I'm more worried about
Matt's advice which is yes it's not the
worst tax advice I've ever heard but oh
if we did we could do a show on a
hovercraft they'll be on air because
this not biscuiting now the legal system
on Sark also has something called try
and pronounce French again here which is
never never great all great
the clamor are all clammy arrows is that
on the lies the hue and cry for a
criminal or something like that
oh it's connects to hue and cry I
absolutely give you for apprehending a
felon on this case but what is the human
crop hearing cries is a an ancient thing
we're in a community you would be
responsible for raising the hue and cry
if someone have committed a crime what's
passing through your community it's all
pile on perfectly in a legal term right
so it's it's like the law but on a small
island where the law everett operates
like American football this is this is
not on Sartre I should put it all up for
a hue and cry all able-bodied men upon
hearing the shouts were obliged to
assist oh that sounds like so much fun
this is the human fiber this is not
clamor
a rrow I know har oh oh this is kind of
an opposite this is not going to catch
someone this is to ignore sorry to say
professionally ignoring crimes weight
tax haven of a craft what hovercraft
it's disguised as a barn on disguises a
load of money
is that a formal way of saying gear off
my land
it's it's not gay off my land but yeah
it is a formal thing that you do this is
annoying me because I half know this
it's some kind of judicial process where
you effectively bring someone in front
of the king to a judge on our land case
or something like that isn't it it is
the very specific process the procedure
is performed on one's knees steady
everyone before at least two witnesses
in the presence of the wrongdoer
and in the location of the offence all
right
the Creon to the person complaining with
his hand in the air must call out hear
me hear me hear me come to my aid my
prince for someone does me wrong it's a
hell of a safe word with you Matt threw
the orange followed by reciting what
what well-known thing in French Lord's
Prayer yes absolutely right it's been
done recently this
yes it's why I've heard of it it's
because it's in some kind of London
experience really something like a hedge
or a garage or something like that and
the guy is pissing on the verge of
losing the case and as one final
basically legal dick move just drop to
his knees and did that and everywhen oh
that's still enforced that kind of thing
what happens after the Lord's Prayer is
recited what what does what does the
person they are challenging need to do
based on what's already gone before
presumably adopted backwards crab
position walk in a circle full moon but
any other time of the year you have to
go completely rectilinear and shout
something yeah let's go with Latin it is
significantly simpler than that
most things are with doctoral thesis is
that were easier to complete than that
so they just go right yes that's
basically
they just have to stop what they're do
regardless of whether they are legally
entitled to do it or not if that is used
they have to stop and it goes to
adjudication what you've someone got on
their knees and did all of that only to
watch as the bull does a rumble - yeah
and if you call without a valid reason
you pay a fine if you call and how much
is the fine ain't gonna say this is it
is it one that's been set a long time
ago and using that it's gonna be either
ludicrously cheap or ludicrously
expectant actually say it just says a
penalty oh you just have to take a
free-kick didn't we start on football
team like 20 minutes ago I was gonna
bring this back to a later in a little
while we have the legal system of Sark
at some point yourself hold your horses
yes thank you
well they have to take a set of
penalties it's best to sit no no a time
the other team scores the entire Sark
team does that well that would be quite
difficult
how was the population of Sark roughly
doesn't I don't forget some of them are
only there 91 days of the year this is
what I'm trying to build a probably send
the bottler to play for them I was gonna
say I was gonna say something like a
hundred and fifty but when you count
actual residents if it's so easy it
could be in the thousands it's about 600
people so as you can imagine the Sark
football team does not have a lot of
people who are highly qualified to play
football
correct horses the Sark football team
are all human based principles here who
do they play against all the football
teams yes I'm not gonna be pointed out
you know is it the channel League anyone
who wants to come over and play them
hang on I mean I know chaps do we know
seven other people I get an idea yeah
harbercraft from what I've heard of this
team do we need another
11-4 people well this one you're absurd
where I'm getting viewpoint four islands
as well because they're international
matches were in 2003 that's for them
they stood out in the international
match against Gibraltar the Isle of
Wight Greenland and a place I'm gonna
mispronounce the vowel in this called
fryer frozen yogurt
that's Froyo that's the sorbet United
absolutely don't overbuy Jaap yeah so
they have these four matches in 2003 how
did they do all conclusive losses yes
how conclusive very yes double digits
yes takers Gibraltar a full nation now
so do you brought a must have pasted at
least 20 or something 1922 against the
Isle of Wight FIFA member Isle of Wight
Greenland 16 nil against thought fryer
15 Milligan shocked they still tried
loves no no we're gonna do it today it's
just more than the England side do but
we can do this I'm sorry we could be the
first team to go over and get beaten by
sharks yeah goes on the list
yeah would get in all of the salt papers
we would we would dibs on gold you know
for one thing we don't want annex keeper
we want somebody who's not gonna bother
in gold so they went to be fed that is
how it also works in the England team
right I'll book the hovercraft oh we
know I am genuinely Amish I will do this
what it I would serve that as the team
that the first team to lose perfect
we're not from an island that's the only
problem will go and stand on that one
impede on Park put it before take a
picture
oh yeah do you have a phone number for
Sark phone you Latimer phones ringing
what happens is yes takes the message
sounds a bugle for the Lord to come down
and read the proclamation
cries a mainland of challenged us to
football a dual footer you say he says
it is big chair in his Hall as I imagine
he still has so I ring suck now yes yes
it's a genuine thing right you've been
playing good people it hasn't worked out
wish right and we know we are yeah the
peas on Park United take it on and on
that congratulations Gary you win the
show what are you win a bright orange
thing for a large mustelid to bounce on
in isolation
it's a tangerine Wolverine quarantine
trample so do you enjoy that with that
we say thank you to Chris Joel yeah -
Gary darlin - Mac Dre's are they Ivan
Tom Scott we'll see you next time
[Music]